une réunion animée du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu sans surprise le
projet de résolution présenté par les
états unis condamnant l' attaque russe
contre l'ukraine a fait l'objet d'un
veto de la part de la russie la russie
ne peut pas mettre son veto à cette
résolution ne peut pas mettre son veto à
nos voix elle ne peut pas mettre son
veto à la vérité qu'elle ne peut pas
mettre son veto à nos principes
elle ne peut pas mettre son veto au
peuple ukrainien
sur les 15 membres du conseil ont ce
pays ont voté en faveur du texte mais
trois se sont abstenus la chine l'inde
et les émirats arabes unis pékin affirme
être contre la prise de sanctions qui
pleuvent sur la russie de son côté le
secrétaire général de l'onu a appelé à
nouveau à cesser les combats et trouvé
une solution pacifique
l'onu est née de la guerre pour mettre
fin à la guerre
aujourd'hui cet objectif n'a pas été
atteint
mais nous n'abandonnerons jamais nous
devons donner une nouvelle chance à la
paix les soldats doivent retourner dans
leurs casernes
les dirigeants doivent prendre le chemin
du dialogue et de la paix
en début de semaine alors que les forces
russes se rapprocher de kiev
le dirigeant ukrainien volodimir
zelensky a laissé entendre que son pays
pourrait renoncer à son objectif
d'adhésion à l'otan un projet que la
russie considère comme une menace
existentielle pour sa sécurité